[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Roos and I'm Ayanna Webb and
this is your news for Monday August 27th
so today obviously we're not in the
studio oh we are at Wizard World Chicago
we've been having a great time if you
haven't seen any of our pictures or
anything make sure you check that out on
Instagram Twitter Facebook they're all
over the place we've been having a great
time we have it's been a busy weekend
but a fun weekend for sure but let's get
down to the news we have a couple of
stories that are just some general
announcements first of all the 80s
arcade game Galaga
is getting an animated TV series that's
right an animated TV series which seems
like a very strange choice if you ask me
like there really isn't much to that
game besides like shooting some aliens
so I'm really interested to see where
they're gonna take the plot of this and
perhaps one of the other interesting
pieces to this is that it's gonna be
done by the same studio that does Bojack
horseman so will it be some kind of like
meta TV series where like they know
they're in an arcade game will it be
more like wreck-it Ralph kind of a thing
or it's like the characters and the
aliens inside the arcade game or will it
be like a more serious take on some kind
of plot that we add to the game right I
wonder too if because it was in the 80s
if the audience now it's older more
mature as well so maybe they'd be even
open to doing a jerk version yeah some
kind of like gritty reboot because
heaven knows we haven't had a ton of
those recently
that's right but yeah we won't be able
to see that until late 2019 maybe early
2020 it's all still up in the air with
development I didn't really see it
attached to a network at this moment
either so I am very interested to see
what direction they're gonna take this
animated series in also news this week
James Bond's newest movie has been put
on hold
that's right come on in 25 s director
Danny Boyle has stepped away due to
creative differences and as a co-writer
I'm wondering if they're still going to
use the script if they're going to have
to use a new one a hire new director as
well obviously I'm very interested as to
what this means for the future of the
bond 25 film as the release day was
already announced for November of 2019
and it was set to start filming in
December of this year so right I mean
it's always interesting to me when you
see that a director has left because of
creative differences it's like Oh what
does that mean I know right I would like
to know I don't know why I'm sure I'm
sure
we can also speculate in the comments
down below who the next direction might
be you would like to see direct this
Bond film I'd be very interested in
hearing what you have to say yeah yeah
for sure
also this week we got an announcement
that another movie has been put on hold
and that is guardians of the galaxy vol
3 although honestly this doesn't come as
much of a surprise they've obviously
been having a whole bunch of drama James
Gunn was like go of and then they were
still gonna maybe use his script still
so now it's kind of up in the air who
the new director is going to be are they
gonna write a new script and obviously
there were some of the actors who had
come out and said that they stand behind
James Gunn so was there some issues with
maybe actors being a little unwilling to
move forward in the project until things
were righted there's obviously been just
a ton of drama and speculation
surrounding this so it has been
put on hold for the moment which isn't
that big of a deal I guess at the moment
is because we didn't even have a release
date for it anyway
we know it's been it's gonna happen but
there hasn't been a release date date
announced for it so it will just be very
interesting to see what happens moving
forward with this project that's right I
want another one so I will say make it
good and then yes make it happen if it's
not gonna be good we don't need it right
right you know right well and I'm sure
the team not just the actors but
everyone involved on the project seems
very passionate about it and wouldn't
want it to be a subpar project right
they wouldn't want it to be a subpar I
think that's part of the reason why they
stand behind James Gunn they've seen the
script or at least no have worked with
him and have known what to expect while
working with him there's there's sort of
you know like shorthand between all of
them yeah
it yeah it makes sense but it's still
really sad it is it is
well let me brighten your mood it
because Star Wars Episode nine has cast
a new actor and the doctor is Dominic
monoghan that's where I L everybody
Charlie from loss or Mary yes that's all
I know I'm Mary
Lord of the Rings that's right he's
great and I wish we could know obviously
who he's playing but they're very
tight-lipped they're those so that's not
gonna happen anytime soon no so much
secrecy surrounding this movie we don't
know who anyone really has been cast as
except obviously the leads like we know
Ray's gonna be in there right but it's
really interesting to see this cast come
together I wish we could form an
excitement as to like knowing who the
characters are we could maybe like form
an opinion on what the scripts might
entail right there's no way of knowing
he's used to being a fan favorite though
that's Dominic's I can't wait for the
next one well and actually I was reading
that
he had said he would like to be a part
of the Star Wars franchise when force
awakens started filming so it's kind of
like this moment of him being a fan and
going like so pure welcome everybody and
yes very exciting also this week we got
an announcements that Lois Lane is going
to be a part of the CW DC crossover
which she's technically been mentioned
before in Supergirl cat grant does talk
about how you know
Lois Lane is one of her greatest
competitions in the world of reporting
and obviously we've seen Superman quite
a bit already on Supergirl but now it's
been announced that she is going to
officially be a part of the crossover
she won't just be mentioned she will be
part of it so then that also means that
we have Superman involved which again
he's been on Supergirl before but he's
never really been a part of the
crossovers so it'll be very interesting
to see how he like plays into the
dynamic of this world that we've already
established in the DC CW universe no
news yet on when the or sorry who is
going to be cast as Lois Lane but the
crossover is happening in December so
I'm getting really excited about this
year's crossover now we've got Lois Lane
we've got Superman we've obviously got
bat woman we talked about that a couple
weeks ago so I'm a thousand percent in
even contain it so it'll be interesting
again to see when you would want I'm
putting her Lois Lane oh gosh I don't
even know you guys like to see play Lois
Lane
no I know I really don't know I don't
that woman wrong I didn't know yeah so
yeah I'm excited to see I am too also
the last thing of this episode is going
to be that today on twitch starts is the
Pokemon marathon oh boy
twitch will be streaming all the library
of Pokemon including movies yeah and
that will go until 2019 and it starts
today so catch me on Twitch and I assume
that you can find that on the twitch
presents channel because that I am where
they were doing the Doctor Who
well almost all of doctor who literally
possible so check out the twitch
presents channel for Pokemon also we
just wanted to let you know that this
here is our final orbit reports we will
not be coming now however you can always
catch us on top 5 yeah you can always
catch us on those social medias yep
Heather where is that for you you can
find me on Twitter Instagram or twitch
or I stream on Wednesday nights oh there
we go you can take a break from your
Pokemon twitch head on over to Heather's
channel yeah I'm arts you know and then
you can find me on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and I'm sad thanks guys for
checking us out watching interacting
with us we really appreciate it
and there'll be more to come yeah in
other ways in the meantime for the final
time could you please
[Applause]
you